bonjour carlit brouillon bonjour vous
êtes la directrice adjointe de la maison
de ragon et de triolet rhône est là
devant cette maison à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines magnifique
maison est un moulin non pas là tout
allait rouvrir la décoration intérieure
iloilo acheter comme cette maison
alors ils l'ont acheté en 1951 en fait
c'est aragon qui achète la maison pour
l'offrir à triolet là il veut lui offrir
un petit coin de terre de france
elle est russe étrangères c'est
l'étranger voilà césar et on était rusal
a été atteint à dire voilà voilà la la
il s'installe on est angle et puis c'est
aussi un coin
calme propice à l'écriture donc ils vont
venir ici dans des longues périodes
d'écriture ils viennent aussi pour
recevoir des amis puisque c'est une très
grande maison voilà et c'est aussi la
maison des livres puisque c'est ici
qu'ils vont pouvoir stocker leur
bibliothèque
parce que ragots il est plutôt certains
amoureux de paris il adore paris
pourquoi ils s'installent à la campagne
ben c'est pas pour faire de la place
alors c'est le cas c'est une résidence
secondaire et concerts qu'ils ont
toujours leur appartement parisien rue
de varenne mais ils viennent ici le
week-end à certaines périodes elsa
s'était passionné pour le parc pour
l'horticulture et c'est donc voilà c'est
c'est une autre facette d'aragon et
d'alsace et la période d'écriture de
voilà le pari bon élève magnifique cette
maison là on la verra tout à l'heure
mais ça coûte cher dont ils ont des
moyens de l'acheter
il faut qu'ils empruntent alors déjà oui
on est on est en 51 donc c'est déjà pas
au tout début de soirée à l'heure qu'il
est mais c'est vrai qu'ils aiment à le
dire nous nous endettons jusqu'au cou
voilà et puis je pense gallimard a
beaucoup agité a contribué à l'achat de
cette maison
alors on entend un peu d'eau parce que
c'est un boulot mais ce que je vous
propose c'est qu'on aille visiter
l'intérieur un joshua là non on va on va
tomber dans la cuisine à ça c'est ça une
petite d'une pièce importante
oui oui à la part sept sites dont
caroline nous sommes dans la cuisine
c'est une baisse importante
oui c'est une pièce importante edmonde
charles roux nous disait dans la
présidente de l'association
nous disait que c'était un peu le living
room donc à elle nous l'a dit la semaine
dernière quand il y avait monsieur
hollande jack black est venu par les
lieux alors évidemment bon il aimait
bien la cuisine
oui elle aimait bien recevoir se voit
mal un élastique intéressant mais on le
verra dans d'autres lieux dans la maison
ben c'est que il avait des abysses
artistes voilà on retrouve des objets
des amis artistes un peu partout donc
ici dans cette cuisine on a les dessous
de plats réalisés par picasso donc avec
ses colombes les mots visages de la paix
et là on a cette très belles céramiques
de fernand léger c'est moi le cheval
rond et au galop donc c'est fernand
léger qui réalise cette céramique pour
elsa triolet pour son livre la sortie de
son livre le cheval on en voit aussi le
cheval blanc ce sont deux mondes d'elsa
voilà c'est tout simplement pas le banc
des bulls 1 c'est pas mal c'était les
autres ont passé on passe à côté
allez on va dans le bureau d'aragon
ben encore picasso voilà on attendait
dans le bureau là mais picasso dont nous
nous suit on retrouve picasso c'est donc
le roi carnaval qui est dédicacé par
picasso aragon à mon ami aragon et
signés picasso en fait c'est un petit
clin d'oeil parce qu'on retrouve la
colombe avec le trait bleu du visage
voilà cette fameuse colombe de la paix
mais comment vous allez passer une
commande d'aragon un picasso en fait
voilà à aragon doit faire la fiche pour
le congrès mondial de la paix il va tout
de suite chez picasso et il tombe sur
une lithographie en fait une colombe
blanche sur un fond noir
esi voilà c'est ça qui va devenir la
fiche du sne audrey et ça deviendra bien
plus que ça parce que deviendra le
symbole universel de la paix comme et
c'est ça la colombie est alors à côté il
ya des petites blagues à tabac voilà
c'est dit vie du tabac gré en fait là le
tabac qui était distribué aux soldats
pendant la guerre alors c'est vrai que
la guerre une très grande importance
dans le dragon voilà il est mobilisé il
est tout jeune il est médecin auxiliaire
et donc ça va être une période
importante parce que déjà il va il va
buter sur l'horreur de la guerre
donc voilà donc ça aurait bien voila
voila tout à fait tous les livres du
monde réel se termine il se rassurant
sur la guerre et c'est aussi une période
importante parce que c'est là qu'il va
rencontrer andré breton
donc voilà ils vont devenir très amis et
c'est là que je préfère la lettre alors
deux choix d'écrire non non non disons
que je le vois là disons proto
t'apporterai n'était pas tellement sur
les romans en fait donc voilà donc mes
lutins peu jaloux je pose du talent de
drago proches pensent que c'est assez
compliqué mais voilà ils sont fâchés à
un moment mais ils ont quand même été
très amis et le surréalisme a été une
période très importante dans l'écriture
d'aragon et donc voilà ce bio c'est un
bureau donc sur lequel il a écrit
ah oui oui mal à la semaine sainte par
exemple a été dit les yeux la mémoire
voilà il ya plein de textes qui ont été
écrits le dernier
grand livre qu'il a écrit si c'est henri
matisse roman après la mort d'anna il va
regrouper tous les textes qu'il a écrits
sur matisse pour créer ce henri matisse
roman c'est la dernière le dernier livre
qu'il a écrit sur 270 voilà 16 juin 1916
est alors après il viendra un petit peu
moins si ces tests et quand vous leur
maison a eu plutôt voilà la décoration
c'était vraiment elsa et puis c'était
vraiment la maison un leur maison à tous
deux donc c'est vrai que après il va il
va venir - régulièrement puisque vous
parlez de décoration peut-être passé
dans le dans le salon alors ce qu'on a
c'est vraiment la décoration belza voilà
tout à fait donc voilà le salon voilà on
est dans le grand salon est là il ya un
poste de radio l'époque voilà ces deux
postes de la voix de son maître d'aragon
qui marche encore
et il écoutait le disque écoutez léo
ferré voilà une chouette aragon qui
chante aragon c'est le dernier disque
qui l'a écoutée en fait aragon c'est un
poète qui ne ça le dérangeait pas du
tout que les voilà en fait il trouvait
que ça donnait une autre vie à ces
textes et il a toujours été assez proche
des artistes qui ont travaillé
sur son sur ses poèmes comme ferrat
ferré
je ne peux rien révéler de nouveaux
revers tout à faire quelque chose
d'assez original avec grâce et sa toxine
voilà dernier disque qu'il a qui l'a
écoutée s'était fait réchaud tarragone
l'étrangère de tagro et alors ça c'est
ça c'est exceptionnel 7,7
le fantastique devenue fontaine c'est
comme ça qu'elle va nous présente cette
chute de lave ou la roue dans la roue du
moulin est à l'intérieur de la maison
comme voilà alors la route n'y est plus
mais la cage de la roux est toujours là
en tout cas avec booth et bones fikin
ouais il jouait beaucoup avec cette
chute d'eau à aragon
il peut arrêter en fait l'eau avec une
telle manne au dessus donc il jouait
beaucoup avec cette chute d'eau pour
pour dire aux gens que la soirée était
fini ou voilà donc ces voix là aussi il
ya quelques livres
enfin bon c'est pas la grande
bibliothèque c'est une pièce we ou
vivaces et on reçoit mais voila voila
c'est la pièce où ils reçoivent les amis
c'est la décoration dels arts voilà on a
on n'allait pas gai là une sagaie de
tahiti en fait à elsa une wii avec eux
qui son premier mari monsieur le seuil
haut les bisons ont réussi voilà
et elle va habiter à tahiti et donc
voilà il ya pas mal d'objets de taille
tient d'ailleurs des vanneries
donc c'était du tout le point va dans la
décoration tout 4,2 au trio d'elsa au
monde
allons-y alors il y avait le disque de
léo ferré tout à l'heure mais la place
est disque de brassens alors racontez
nous il ya une petite anecdote amusante
c'est un disque on a retrouvé ici avec
cette dédicace aragon avec mes regrets
pour la petite erreur signez pas
brassens
donc c'est vrai qu' on est assez étonné
les chercheurs ces états unis a perdu
d'abord il n'y a pas d'amour heureux
donc c'est vrai que brassens ne chante
pas la dernière strophe donc séparés
c'est peut-être à l'erreur mais en fait
il suffisait de retourner le disque et
on a ici il n'y a pas d'amour heureux
sur un poème de paul fort et paul fort
enlever la balle l'auteur se tromper
d'auteur celui là vous vous chantez
aussi pour le fort brassens
voilà le soin que moi qu'est la même
musique je crois que c'est je vous salue
marie de paul fort qu'est la même
musique qu'il n'y a pas d'amour heureux
c'est peut-être pour ça il faudra
vérifier on existe dans un lieu qui
participent au public qui est accessible
aux chercheurs que la bibliothèque
il yad'autres d'autres livres et une et
trois mille trente mille 30 mise à huy
38 et en plus il ya beaucoup de livres
qui sont dédicacés par les auteurs donc
c'est vrai qu'elle fait un travail de
recherche qui peut être fait sur les
subventions sur les échanges entre 1 et
le fait que cette bibliothèque soit
accessible aux chercheurs
ça fait partie un peu
des destinations de la maison
d'aujourd'hui des volontés dargaud et de
ce que ce qu'est la maison aujourd'hui
la maison d'arrêt contre il y aurait
aujourd'hui voilà en fait aragon
lorsqu'il est que cette maison à l'êta
et sept maisons et ses manuscrits
il veut que ce soit un lieu de mémoire
mais aussi un lieu ouvert la recherche
est ouvert à la création contemporaine
donc on a fait ce fait voilà nous on
essaye vraiment que ce soit un lieu
vivant
on fait beaucoup d'expositions d'art
contemporain 4,5 par an on fait des
rencontres avec des poètes contemporains
dont fait du théâtre
voilà on fait de la chanson puisqu'il à
l amiante
donc c'est vrai que on essaye vraiment
que ce lieu soit vivant et c'est pas
seulement voilà c'est évidemment on a vu
tout à l'heure et c'est vrai les amitiés
avec picasso mais c'est vrai que c'est
vivant quazal va vous avez une
exposition de dire aux incessamment
hervé di rosa
voilà ce que ce cas ragon vous êtes son
temps avec en tant qu'hôte des
découvreurs de talents on le on le fait
aujourd'hui en montrant l'art de notre
temps et l'art contemporain
donc on à hervé di rosa en ce moment
jusqu'à la fin de l'année donc voilà on
peut on peut venir alors les expositions
et longueuil est donc parfait dans le
jardin ou sinon voilà aux beaux jours on
fait toujours une exposition de
peintures sculptures et on a même
maintenant un parc de
deux sculptures donc on a une vingtaine
d'oeuvres qui sont en permanence ici que
des artistes nous ont laissés à la fin
des expositions donc on a un petit
jardin de sculptures en permanence hélas
pour les nostalgiques il ya aussi qu'on
s'appelle un parc et un bal parker balle
partait alors quelques magnifiques
voilà ça c'est un peu une nouveauté en
fait on vient d'installer un un bal parc
et dans le parc donc c'est un bal
parquet qui a été fait en 1946 c'est un
super bon ben voilà il c'est le seul
inscrit aux monuments historiques
en avance à ma connaissance et voilà
donc c'est en bois et vitraux et des
danses et voilà après guerre les gens
alors nous on n'en sera peut-être mais
on fera aussi beaucoup de rencontres
avec des poètes contemporains avec on
l'a fait fuir leurs maisons
voilà ça fait vivre la maison merci
infiniment car le nouveau je vous
remercie